muy buenos días a todos hoy os vamos a
hablar de un tema fascinante imaginad
que dividimos las reservas de petróleo
de cada país por su número de habitantes
en lugar de renta per cápita
obtendríamos algo así como petróleo por
persona cuál crees que es el país con el
indicador más alto probablemente algunos
estáis pensando en aves audita en
emiratos o en kuwait pues no
la respuesta es oro en la cndh ya
groenlandia tiene casi tanto petróleo
como rusia pero tan solo la población de
ávila y os preguntaréis siendo así
porque no es el país más rico del mundo
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Aplausos]
[Música]
una vez te has planteado cómo es la vida
en lo que algunos consideran una utopía
un otro piano no exista la propiedad
privada donde la gente mantenga sus
tradiciones milenarias donde todos
vivamos en una especie de tribu si
quieres puedes probarlo no tienes más
que hacer las maletas cogerlas y mudarte
anouk en la capital de groenlandia
efectivamente el país de los esquimales
en realidad el término más correcto
sería inuit al parecer la palabra
esquimal no les hace mucha gracia el
pueblo inuit ha sido capaz de mantener
su modo de vida intacto durante el paso
de los siglos por supuesto si en algún
momento durante este viaje durante esta
aventura echas de menos el confort
occidental no te preocupes en
groenlandia encontrarás supermercados
donde poder encontrar prácticamente
cualquier cosa además también hay
edificios tan impresionantes como este
centro cultural que están
y os preguntaréis quién paga todo esto
lo paga dinamarca groenlandia es un
estado libre asociado del gobierno danés
eso significa que para casi todos los
efectos son independientes tienen su
propia policía sus propios colegios
donde por supuesto se enseña el idioma y
nuit y tiene sus propias leyes sus
propios impuestos menos en lo referente
al ejército y política exterior en eso
todo les viene dado de dinamarca a
cambio los daneses subvencionan todo lo
subvencionable colegios libros tiendas
de ultramarinos supermercados todo todo
lo que os podéis imaginar está pagado
desde copenhague los daneses por su
parte lo que reciben es un territorio
enorme sobre el que colocar factorías de
pescado mucho del pescado del bacalao
que comemos en europa está pescado por
barcos daneses y procesado en
groenlandia y por supuesto también
montan ahí sus bases militares por
ejemplo la base aérea de tule de la que
hemos oído hablar muchas veces en
películas videojuegos etcétera eso está
en groenlandia la economía groenlandesa
por otro lado no es que sea nada del
otro mundo son 60 mil habitantes la
mitad
se dedica a la pesca tradicional y la
otra mitad se dedica a ser funcionarios
ya gestionar ese dinero que les llega de
dinamarca que es con lo que realmente
viven sin embargo los groenlandeses
siempre han sido muy nacionalistas
siempre han pedido más independencia al
gobierno de dinamarca
[Música]
los daneses por su parte tampoco les han
puesto ninguna pega porque a fin de
cuentas para ellos groenlandia no es más
que una fuente de problemas se ve muy
bien en la serie de televisión volviendo
y habla de política danesa es una serie
danesa y en la que podemos ver la
opinión de la sociedad la opinión de los
políticos al respecto qué bueno
consideran que groenlandia es un
territorio que reacciona saber muy bien
qué hacer
[Música]
pero ahora fonseca las cosas parecen
estar cambiando en los últimos años se
ha descubierto que groenlandia tiene
petróleo mucho petróleo pero no sólo
hablamos de oro negro también tienen
todo tipo de minerales uranio hierro
zinc diamantes tan solo en gas natural
se estima que el oro en la aliá tiene la
tercera parte del gas que aún queda por
descubrir en el mundo una tercera parte
de todo el gas que se estima descubrir
en todo el mundo respecto al petróleo
convencional hablamos del 10 por ciento
es más o menos las mismas reservas que
tiene rusia y todo esto repito en un
país con menos de 60 mil habitantes en
otras palabras casi podemos decir que a
los inuit les ha tocado la lotería no te
parece así cauto pero no todo es tan
fantástico como parece porque es cierto
que groenlandia tiene unos recursos
naturales envidiables pero también
tienen una capa de hielo cubriendo toda
la isla que en algunos puntos desde más
de un kilómetro de grosor claro hacer
una mina en españa' puede ser más fácil
o más difícil pero en esencia es hacer
un agujero en el suelo en groenlandia
primero tienes que atravesar que perfora
una capa de hielo de más de un kilómetro
de grosor lo cual hace que sea mucho más
caro extraer cualquier mineral no
hablamos ya del petróleo casi todo el
petróleo con holandés está en la costa
en la zona marítima y lo tienes que
explotar con barcos barcos que se ponen
muy cerquita de la costa
[Música]
en la costa con holandesa están cayendo
constantemente bloques de hielo que son
los famosos iceberg el iceberg que
hundió el titanic venía de groenlandia
imagínate que estás con tu barquito
petrolero extrayendo tu crudo y se cae
de repente un bloque de hielo del tamaño
de las torres kio a mí no me gustaría
estar ahí eso además de arriesgado es
caro hace que el barril de crudo en
groenlandia sea mucho más caro que el
barril de crudo en arabia saudi
a esto hay que sumarle el hecho de que
en groenlandia no hay carreteras no hay
carreteras con lo cual los minerales o
los recursos que extraiga solamente los
puedes transportar o bien por barco o
bien por avión eso encarece muchísimo
los costes y ya por encima de todo está
el caos legislativo groenlandés en
groenlandia por no haber ni siquiera
propiedad privada con lo cual las
empresas lo piensan dos veces antes de
acercarse a la isla a explotar los
recursos esto podría explicar por qué
muchas inversiones se han parado los
últimos dos años
extraño que yo coincida con la baja en
los precios del petróleo como es tan
caro explotar los recursos de
groenlandia y el beneficio desaparece
cuando hay que vender a precios tan
reducidos eso también explicaría por qué
el nuevo presidente groenlandés que
lleva alrededor de dos años en el
gobierno ha dejado un lado el tema de la
independencia porque se ha dado cuenta
de que groenlandia necesita de dinamarca
y de sus subvenciones para seguir
sobreviviendo groenlandia es un país
desconocido para casi todo el mundo pero
tiene un potencial de crecimiento
inmenso que ya no pueden explotar sus
recursos naturales pero el día en que lo
hagan van a llenar las páginas de los
periódicos además es un tema muy
interesante porque es uno de los pocos
territorios vírgenes que aun quedan en
el mundo desde visual político lo vamos
a seguir muy de cerca no sólo lo
concerniente a groenlandia sino a toda
la política del ártico que cada vez es
más importante si tenéis alguna duda o
queréis aportar algo dejar un comentario
muchas gracias y está otro día
[Música]